Time for a little honesty, I quit piano lessons
when I was a kid.
And my dad always said I would regret it.
Well dad, this me, admitting you’re right.
Science has known for a while that learning
to play an instrument is good for kids.
Kids who take music lessons have higher grades
and graduation rates than their non-musical
peers.
Some researchers even claim that it can boost
IQ as well as academic performance.
A recent study from researchers at the University
of Vermont College of Medicine added another
reason to the list of why I should not have
quit piano lessons.
Learning an instrument can help grow the young
and changing brain.
The study looked at brain scans of 232 kids
ages 6-18 over a few years to see what playing
an instrument would do.
The researchers looked one region in particular,
the cortex.
This part of the brain changes in thickness
as kid’s brains grow.
This recent study found that the more a child
practiced an instrument the faster their brains
organized and the faster their cortical lining
thickened.
These physical changes in the brain led to
important changes in the kids behavior.
They were better at paying attention, managing
anxiety, and controlling their emotions and
impulses.
This isn’t the first study to toot the horn
of musical training.
Previous studies show that learning an instrument
boosts memory and grades.
Researchers from Northwestern University studied
a group of kids from The Harmony Project,
a music education program in inner city LA.
Not only did the participants in the program
do better in school, they had higher grades
and graduation rates, but the study showed
that kids who play an instrument for two years
can distinguish the difference in sounds like
Pill and Bill better than their non-musical
peers which develops important skills like
communication and reading.
But the benefits aren’t just for kids, learning
to play an instrument can create neurological
connections that can last a life time.
Playing an instrument involves many parts
of the brain, visual and auditory regions,
motor control and even emotional processing
centers are activated.
And this leads musicians to have better neuroplasticity,
which means their brains are better at changing
and rewiring themselves over time and helps
when old age brings a decline in cognitive
function.
But these cognitive benefits aren’t necessarily
unique to musicians, really any kind of specialized
training can boost the brain in different
ways.
Now the real question is, does this work for
grown ups?
Could learning an instrument later in life
confer the same benefits? because I could
seriously use a brain boost.
Most research indicates the strongest effects
occur when learning takes place in childhood.
While there’s not a lot of research right
now on how learning an instrument later in
life affects adult brains, one researcher
from the University of Zurich says that adults
over the age of 65 who pick up an instrument
had important changes in regions of the brain
that control hearing, coordination and memory.
Learning any skill at any age helps new neuron
growth, so maybe there’s some hope for me.
To learn more about music, like where it came
from or why it feels amazing, check out the
links here